for three consecutive days johnny depp
has been in the witness box becoming
animated at times alleging the tip of
his finger was severed when amber haired
through a bottle
but the mood in the courtroom changed
when his ex-wife's lawyers
cross-examined him showing a video she'd
secretly recorded of the actor banging
cupboard doors in his west hollywood
home
[Music]
i did not uh
try to intimidate miss heard if she was
intimidated
why was she filming if she was scared to
death why didn't she leave
earlier jurors had been shown a picture
of bags of marijuana in his recording
studio
and several pictures of words he'd
written in his own blood after the
finger injury
johnny depp was asked about text
messages he'd sent to the actor paul
bettany one reading let's burn amber
another let's join her before we burn
her about text messages to marilyn
manson discussing drug taking
and about his relationship with elton
john from whom he sought help when
trying to get sober
beyond the trial his representatives
issued a statement explaining that
burning and drowning were references to
a scene in the monthly python film
implying they'd been taken out of
context
[Applause]
depp's suing heard for 50 million
dollars over an article she wrote about
domestic violence
and she's counter-suing him for 100
million dollars
the trial scheduled to run for another
three weeks
david blevins sky news virginia